Rhonda santis wants to be America's next
president the controversial Governor
from Florida is the leading Republican
Challenger to Donald Trump but can he
really win for a while Ron DeSantis was
a vocal supporter of the former
president make America great again he
elected Trump's mannerisms and presented
himself as an enemy of the left Donald
Trump even backed his winning campaign
to become Florida's governor in 2018.
hey great gentleman Ron descent but the
relationship has since soured there it
is Trump at 71 Rhonda sanctimonious at
10 last year Rhonda Sanders became the
Republican's big winner when he was
remargined and now he's trying to
position himself as a trumpy
conservative but less erratic than the
man himself
he signed a number of controversial
bills in Florida the process turning the
state into one of the toughest on
abortion immigration and LGBT rights how
many parents want their kindergartners
to have transgenderism or something
injected into classroom instruction and
getting into a fight with Disney over
diversity but the sentence's big problem
is the Republican primary voters show no
sign of falling out of love with Donald
Trump no matter what he does
Rhonda Santos's popularity compared with
that of the former president has
fluctuated but Mr Trump now has a big
lead whatever happens next DeSantis has
put Florida at the heart of the
country's culture wars and may continue
to make a mark on America
yeah yeah